الجبهه المباشره بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني لا تتحرك بشكل ملحوظ منذ
اسابيع على الاقل ومناطق السيطره ثابته
باستثناء خروقات بدات تتحدث عنها كياف ومن
ابرزها تحرك جبهه خركيف الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بدات عمليات اجلاء في المناطق
المحيطه بكوبيانسك مع نجاح القوات الروسيه
في التقدم ومحاولات اوكرانيه لوقف هذا
التقدم
التطور الميداني هذا لا يخفي عاملا اكثر
اهميه تبدل واضح في استراتيجيه الهجوم
المضاد الاوكراني وتكتيكاته بدايه وجه
الهجوم الاوكراني معوقات جامه تعلقت
بتحصينات روسيه على طول خط المواجهه من
خييرسون في الجنوب وصولا الى الشمال وهذه
التحصينات محميه بدورها بحقول الغام
متعدده
وهذا ما دفع اوكرانيا نحو تكتيكات جديده
استنزاف الجيش الروسي في نقاط تفوقه ضربات
بعيده المدى تستهدف بشكل خاص طرق الامداد
الروسيه والبنيه التحتيه للنقل العسكري
شبه جزيره القرم هي المفتاح في استراتيجيه
الاوكرانيه الجديده استهدف الجيش
الاوكراني الجسرين الاساسيين الواصلين
اليهار الذي يربط شبه جزيره القرم بجنوب
اوكرانيا وجيسترا كورتش الذي يربط شبه
الجزيره بروسيا والذين يستخدمهما الجيش
الروسي كخطوط امداد اساسيه لتبقى سيبا
ستوبول تحت الاستهداف المتكرر بهجمات
بطائرات مسيره تتم بشكل متواتر وفي وقت لا
يمكن الحسم بنتيجه استراتيجيه الاوكرانيه
الجديده على الهجوم المضاد
خبراء عسكريون ان السياسه الاستنزاف قد لا
تكون تكتيكا اوكرانيا منفردا روسيا بدورها
تضرب على الوتر نفسه تستهدف بشكل خاص
الاسلحه والذخائر الغربيه وتحاول ابقاء
الجيش الاوكراني منشغلا بمواجهات ميدانيه
لدفع المزيد من جنود الاحتياط الى خطوط
الجبهات وبالتالي حرمان الجيش الاوكراني
من القوات المتاحه للتناوب في القتال او
الرد على اي تحول في ساحه المعركه